they're an unassuming Bunch you'd be
forgiven for missing the pictures
outside Houston Station
but these strikes are bringing the
country to a standstill again
the rmt union rejected on behalf of its
members a nine percent pay rise over two
years that was linked to Major workplace
reforms it's not acceptable it doesn't
meet the the demands in the dispute they
know that they knew knew that when it
was offered and certainly when they
clarified what they meant by what they
want us to do is call off the dispute
and then go into another set of
negotiations without any leverage at the
table we simply can't do that you don't
disarm yourself halfway through a
campaign and they're asking us to call
off all our action to declare that the
dispute is over when only half of the
issues have been negotiated so the
24-hour strike went ahead a day after
train drivers belonging to the aslav
union also walked out little or no train
Services were running across large parts
of the country these are the first
Nationwide rail strikes since February
and the rmt union has had its mandate
extended for another six months raising
the possibility or further strike action
but no side is backing down with the
government adamant that its latest
payoffer is its best and final proposal
so don't be fooled by the brief lull
we've just had this is a bitter grinding
dispute with no end in sight
as ever it's the passengers that are
losing out no side wants to be held
responsible so the blame game is in full
swing
the dispute has been toxic unfortunately
and it's really disappointing that the
rmt haven't put an offer to to its
members uh speaking to some of my
colleagues who are members of the r d I
know that they're they're angry that
they haven't been given that opportunity
to help resolve this dispute so
that their patients is waning but many
others are still
us to do so much and they obviously you
know work really hard I just think they
should be getting paid more to be honest
it's disrupted our plans
we're on our way to Eurostar so it has
incurred extra costs for us today they
should settle to be perfectly honest
like the other
um unions have settled and it's
disrupting people's lives it's been over
a year since this dispute began and
while deals are being struck across
other parts of the public sector the rmt
union is not backing down garbage no one
Sky News